so I may just said to you right this is
this is what where you can do it and I
have picked up simple example where most
of you can let the numbers are not too
complicated feel oh I can kind of see
that right and it only takes a simple
number to pull out the front okay this
is not the only way and sort of the fact
that we can do is sort of rides a little
bit on the fact that the numbers are so
easy if the numbers weren't a bit more
messy or if you didn't have something as
straightforward here you can have
another whole function there this kind
of technique becomes less and less
useful because it only works in simple
cases okay so we're going to try
something else and that's what this son
that's what this is about this is really
a fancy word for using chain rule
backwards reverse channel it's a version
of reverse chain rule and the way you
can see that is here you go 4x squared
here right whether you are whether that
those two send integrals that we've just
written on the board came from is
there's a simpler version of this
without all this net on a business right
what's the very first thing that we
stated just for a result will give us
this smiley bus what would that be one
on very good okay so you're this kind of
thing happening and that's just regular
old sine inverse okay now when you have
a look at that
long story i'll explain later um what do
you have a look at this feeling this
okay what is really saying is there's
something it's being squared and then
that's what's going to end up on duty oh
ok but if you started without that if
you started for something like he are
that of course something else will get
squared that's where you end up ok does
that make sense so when I see that I've
got two choices the first way is I can
think about this guy and say well I just
want a single x squared it so that's why
I'll take out that factor too that
leaves me with a single exquisite or
alternatively i can say i want the one
there see how I've got a warrant here
I've got a one there and that's exactly
what I want the other thing that needs
to get mucking about with is this ok so
I say well where did that come from
here's the methodologies know so you can
say this is meka the one he comes number
two ok i will flag it right now this
method the second approach for this
question is going to be longer ok it's
going to be like why why did we go about
this way when we could have done this
this simple part and the answer is if
your question is not so simple then you
can't do it just in three lines and not
just it's a you can't just do a three
lines but there's lots more places for
errors to creep them because you just
start to do the bubbles in your head
gets very confused so here's what I'm
going to suggest instead I'm going to
saying let u equal to X so i'm going to
introduce a substitution right that's
what's implied by chamber ok after
because you're getting quite put it now
or just a chain rule in our heads right
but this is where it all comes from this
is what's happening in the background i
am taking two x because what i do is i
see this part underneath the arm in the
integrand I say look this guy here is
really to X or square do you see that so
in other words i'm searching for
essentially bought this thing whatever
it is that's been squared in this case
it's 2x now what I'm going to do
therefore is i'm going to substitute
here everything on this in the integrand
i want to change it into you
and therefore if everything is in terms
of you that's the variable then I want
to instead of integrating with respect
to X I want to interact with respect to
you right so I'm going to change the
function of integrating and then I'm
going to change the variable I'm
integrating with respect you does that
make sense so to do that instead of D
accidents I want to use adding some
connection between DX oh do you so I'm
going to use this I can say I could
differentiate this with respect to that
right so therefore do you on DX this is
just like tyo DX by except i'll just
give it a different name in this case
simple the answer is do okay I'm gonna
do one more thing here don't write this
down sometimes you will see I certainly
seen it here though in different places
and I've said it before myself sometimes
you'll see at this line what's the way
we would write it in this case some
people will write this okay I just pause
again like I said nobody's down why
would people write this okay and the
answer is this slide here is what i'm
going to substitute into here right all
i should say 2x there so it'll just
become 1 minus u squared okay which is
exactly what i want you see that one
bite of something squared and then they
say why need to get rid of all the X is
there done I need to get rid of this DX
right so a natural thing to do is I'll
take this equation here and I'll
rephrase it I'll make this subject d XR
around can flip it around you see what I
mean ok so then what I'm going to
eventually do what that results in it
I'll put half to you up there does that
make sense
now numerically everything will work
everything will come out in the wash
we've looked before at the beginning of
the inverse functions we said look dy/dx
d'action do I they really do behave kind
of like a normal fraction as I said
cancel out they become one I'm going to
encourage you not to write it like this
and the reason why is because let's just
think back to what DX why do you and all
that kind of thing where do they come
from and what do they mean because even
though they behave a lot like a normal
fraction these are their own normal
numbers what are they yeah it's some
infinitesimally small thing okay now in
the same way that you know we can say
something like this okay i can say that
i can put infinity in here and i can
work with it because we understand
what's going on like our denominators
getting big whole numbers getting small
if i go all the way all the way i'll get
20 yes so we sort of understand what's
going on here Ben infinity is not a
number right it's not like i can
substitute u infinity in that's the
whole point of using limits and in the
same way these guys are the opposite of
infinities we actually call them
infinitesimal right there things that
are microscopically small so it doesn't
really make sense to say that this
microscopic is small thin which is meant
to be behaving just like zero just like
this is something that's behaving just
like infinitely luggage that one is half
the size of the other it doesn't really
make sense these are not numbers that
sort of could operate on their own this
line is mere not technically correct the
reason we can work with it like say here
why is this guy hanging on seemingly by
himself is the address he is not by
himself what's he paired with
it's paired with this right now if you
remember the whole point of this is that
this is a sum of something times
something one of these two things meant
to come together and form think way back
to the very start of integration it's it
is tiny little rectangle like you
remember that and we're adding up an
infinite series of really really thin
rectangles so the reason why this guy
seems to be there on his own is here's
the width and here's the height right so
it's like ok these two things operate
together and here these two things
operate together because there's a ratio
between but these this number really
should have been his numbers shouldn't
be on their own they're not meant to
live like that in the same way you can't
put infinity inside an equation you
can't write this really that's it's not
a number that can be substituted it's an
idea ok so the same thing is happening
here I'm going to encourage you not to
write that even if you think of here I
think is a better more technical way to
write and you can weaken Pakistan the
difference is almost nothing i'm going
to write it ok and the reason this is a
little bit a little better is because
the the DXi stay together it's still a
derivative I've done this because before
remember I made DX the subject because
I'd like one there's DX day I better
substitute here ok here i have made one
the subject the useful thing about one
is that i can put one whoever i like
right i can multiply something by one
and it doesn't change what it is ok so
therefore i'm ready now all right now
right I'm ready to do all of my
substitutions at this point I'm ready to
change what the function is that I'm
integrating and I'm ready to change what
the variable is that I've integrated
into space let's do it so I've got that
question is there one or
where does something ok I'll show you in
some ways it does matter because
multiplication is commutator so i can
rearrange however i like because it
really is this times this so so long as
I x 1 somewhere in the chain you'll see
what happens ok I'm going to do one
thing before I do the substitution which
is I'm going to include this slide here
to make clear why is it that I'm doing
any of this now why did I choose to X so
this is going to become this ok now this
line I'm pretty directly parallel of
this one because each one is our slight
algebraic twist in order to use a
difference there'd integral ok so in the
first case the one you suggested to me
at the beginning I tried to reshape it
so it looks like that does that make
sense in this case the second one I
tried to reshape this so it looks like
this so I've got a one- something
underneath the square root does that
make sense ok so just reread it just a
little bit now having done all of this
work over here and i put this like on
the right-hand side of my normal working
the house of space over there are going
to make all the substitutions i need you
for starters i can see on the underneath
the square root that's just going to be
1 minus u square cool that's handy at
this point i'm now going to use my last
slide over there on the left hand side
to change the variable integration so
i'm going to do this a half do u DX DX
ok so you see like i'm multiplying by 1
so i could put this guy this is what i
mean i can put him anywhere i like
within this integral ok but having done
this because it does function like a
normal fraction those two will cancel
this is the chamber part right I
literally do I DX equals that are out
and the two chains that you do use
cancel so here it's too d axis that
cancel
so now we're going to bring that half at
the throat this is the integral of this
and you can see at this point see how
this is parallel to what I was working
up before the half has come up front
except the one thing that's different is
because i'm not using an X on a 4 X on
eight instead i'm using this right yes
so the U equals 2x just hops right into
place because that's that's the fall i'm
using ok make sense you see out I didn't
now as I've just put this is
considerably longer considerably longer
but this method is a lot more versatile
to take on harder things where the
numbers are not just going to be so
straightforward